life is as harsh as you think it might
even be worse but you are way tougher
than you think if you turn around and
confront it i believe that you should
struggle uphill towards the city of god
on your crutches you're full of
biological potential that won't be
realized unless you move yourself around
in the world into different challenging
circumstances and that'll turn on
different circuits want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
small steps to move your life forward
with jordan peterson enjoy
okay let's kick it off with step number
one structure your life properly
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done man learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day done by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive advantage look
will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be promoted assuming you have a clue as
a boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine and then learn
to use a calendar like google calendar
most of you many of you out there do not
use a calendar okay a calendar is not a
prison and it's not a tyrant not if you
use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's two too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you're going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it
and or aim for the opposite because
that's how you get out of it step number
two find meaning you need a meaning to
sustain you through the vicissitudes of
life okay well try to debate that it's
like his life painful yes is it anxiety
provoking yes is it uncertain yes
is it painful beyond bearing sometimes
yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the central
point holds
okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful
okay so you need a sustaining meaning
well where do you find that
well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and other people step number
three take your place in the world it's
good for you to go take your place in
the world have some ambition have some
have a vision have a goal have a
strategy try to try to be a good person
in not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that i've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learn to articulate better
is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what well that's whatever
your aspiration is you have to have a
name okay well what should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say what why do something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile usually judge
them positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves but you want to be completely
useless so other people have to take
care of you that's pretty pathetic and
maybe you could get your act together so
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and maybe you could even do
better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community well good for you that's
that's responsibility and that's an aim
step number four treat yourself with
care treat yourself
like you're someone that you care about
i read this this
piece of work by jung a long while back
and it was a meditation on
the injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated something like that and what
jung pointed out which i really liked
was that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people
it was an invitation to reciprocity it
was something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated
like you were taking care of yourself
not how you would like people to respond
to you it's more important than that
it's like imagine you had a child that
you really cared for and and someone
said well
people will treat this child exactly
like you want them to but you have to
figure out what that is and so then
you'd have to sit down for like a month
and you'd think okay well how do you
want your child to be treated you don't
want everyone just to be nice to him you
know you want people to challenge him
and you want people to discipline him
and you want people to tell him when
he's wrong it's like you don't just want
everyone to be nice that's that's
pathetic it's pathetic
there's no challenge in that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and well you'd like people to fawn all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's that's not something you'd wish
for for someone that you were taking
care of and then then there's an
additional problem which is it's often
the case that people will treat other
people better than they treat themselves
that happens extremely
frequently so one of the things i
pointed out chapter two was that if you
have a dog and you take him to a vet and
the vet gives you your prescription
medicine you'll go buy the medicine and
you will give it to the dog and you will
do it properly but if you go yourself to
a doctor and you get a prescription
there's one that there's a 30 chance you
won't even pick up the medication
and if you do there's a 50 chance that
you won't administer it to yourself
properly
and so i really thought about that when
i first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts i thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously you'll do it for
something you care about and you're
conscientious enough so you'll actually
do it so like why wouldn't you do it for
you your dog likes you you know even
your dog would rather that you did but
but you don't you don't and and it's
actually one of the reasons that modern
medicine doesn't work nearly as well as
it could because people just don't take
their medication you make the world a
much better place a much worse place if
you don't take care of yourself so you
should bloody well take care of yourself
you know because
well that's what the chapters about it's
partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that western
civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark and so it's
not just so that you feel better and not
just so that you're a number one lobster
not none of those things you need to
take care of yourself because you're in
the best position to do that and it's
necessary for you to take care of
yourself despite the fact that we're
mortal and vulnerable and self-conscious
and capable not only capable of doing
terrible things but actually do them
despite all that
you you're still you still have that
responsibility
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there step number five practice
continually of course you struggle to
remember it in your day-to-day life
because life is difficult and it's
harder to do things than not to do them
and it's harder to do them well than to
do them badly you know and it's easy to
sit around and be hopeless i don't mean
it's emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and to fall back into your old habits
and to not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice and i think a good
example of that is something like weight
lifting you know if you start a
weightlifting program which i would
recommend by the way because it it's
tremendously advantageous physically and
cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six-month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and i
did mention the future authoring program
earlier and
one of the things i would recommend too
is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed
it just means that you had a cigarette
you can start stopping again the next
day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself properly if you're
pursuing them but you want them to be
small enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of implementing
them step number six consult your
resentment i think
a tremendous amount of what you might
regard as
shadow integration which
in
the parlance of behavioral psychologists
would be something like assertiveness
training right it's training and how to
stand up for yourself and and for your
let's say for your better self which
would be the self that you could use
productively over a medium to long
period of time that would be of use to
you but also views to people around you
so it's a self that's bounded by the
necessity of taking care of yourself but
also simultaneously taking care of the
people around you
i think that the simplest way to start
that work
is to consult your resentment you know
it's easy to become bitter about life
and to become angry because of course
life is difficult and it's full of
disappointments and
people are also subject to betrayal on
the part of themselves and on the part
of people that hypothetically care for
them and so it's easy to get bitter
and to be resentful
and
resentment is a very useful emotion even
though i think it's one of the most
uh
damaging emotions if it's not dealt with
properly so if you're resentful
basically means
only one of two things it either means
you should grow up and quit whining and
get on with your life or it means that
you're being subject to
tyrannical forces of one form or another
maybe emanating from you maybe a
consequence of the natural environment
maybe a consequence of society you're
being subject to tyrannical forces and
you're not
uh putting your own
best interests forward like in that
broader sense that i described and i
don't mean your selfish narrow
interests that only serve the purposes
of instantaneous gratification i mean
your own best interests in terms of
developing your character over the span
of your life
if you're resentful
it either means that you're immature and
that you should grow the hell up and so
you need to figure out how much of your
resentment is is is that and and maybe
allied with the desire to find other
things or people to blame
but the other possible option is that
you have something to say or do right
because you're in a situation
where
you're violating your own internal
ethical standards
and you're being required pressured
let's say to say things you don't
believe or to do things that you believe
to be wrong and you need to
determine you need to start to
strategize and plan how you can rectify
that so that you can say what you mean
like if you're negotiating with a
marital partner for example and there
are
issues in your marriage that aren't
making you happy well the first thing is
you have to take note of that right to
see that you're actually unhappy
the second is that you have to be
willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to sort out
what's disturbing you you're going to
have to lay your concerns out on the
table
and say well look this is bothering me
you don't have to say well i'm right and
you're wrong and you have to fix this
you have to say well i've noticed that
this pattern of interaction or lack of
interaction say in our relationship is
making me resentful and angry and the
danger of that of course is you're going
to take it out on yourself and your
partner the danger is passion passive
aggressiveness
you know you're not going to respond to
your partner positively when they do
something good if you're resentful about
them
and you're not going to respond to
yourself properly and so you have to lay
it out on the table but sort of in a
spirit of ignorant humility it's like
look i'm frustrated i'm feeling this way
about our relationship here's what i
think might be going wrong maybe on my
part and maybe on your part and here's
what i envision as a possible solution
that's also really necessary if you're
going to say what you have to say which
is to manifest yourself properly in the
world is you can't just complain about
what's wrong you have to think well what
would my minimal preconditions for
satisfaction be you have to offer that
to the person that you're negotiating
with
and so
then you learn to abide by the truth to
the degree that you can do that and no
one does it perfectly you know but
it it's very useful because
you're not storing up
a whole
sequence of memories about how you were
unfairly treated and abused and betrayed
instead you're trying to stay on top of
it and to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself
and to accept that that's the case and
then to analyze that to see if it's your
problem like i said with regards to
maturity or if it indicates that there's
an injustice
in the manner in which
you and the world are interacting and
then to work to set that right even in
small ways and
so it's it's a matter of character
logical development step number seven
make good friends make friends with
people who want the best for you and
that's a meditation on my own childhood
and adolescence to some degree
i had friends who wanted the best for me
and friends who didn't and you know they
were friends who
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up then they're
generally not that happy about it you
know they try to top your accomplishment
with one of their own hypothetical or
real or put down what you're doing or
offer you a cigarette if you're trying
to quit and you've kind of done that
successfully or a drink if you've been
drinking too much and are trying to stop
being an alcoholic you know or or
yeah they're cynical and bitter and and
devoted towards no good and sometimes
that's family members too and sometimes
it's even part of you you know but
this chapter is a injunction to people
is like
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself you have an
ethical responsibility to surround
yourself with people who have the
courage and
and faith and
wisdom
to wish you well when you've done
something good
and to stop you when you're doing
something destructive and if your
friends aren't like that then they're
not your friends and maintaining your
friendships with them might not even be
in their interest and so it's a tricky
argument to make because i'm not saying
you know whenever anyone's in trouble
you should you know
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks that's that's not
the idea
the idea is that but i had a couple of
rules i didn't write about one was be
careful
uh be careful about whom you share good
news with and another was be careful
about whom you share bad news with and
everyone those rules ring in people's
minds quite quickly a friend is someone
you can share good news with you know
you go to them and you say hey look this
good thing happened to me and they say
look i'm so happy that that happened to
you like way to be and they don't think
god damn it why didn't that happen to me
and like you know you didn't deserve it
here's a bunch of reasons you're stupid
and why it won't work it's like that's
not helpful and so i would say like if
people are
you know what the other thing people are
doing if they're trying to drag you down
let's say is they're trying to see if
you'll put up with it because they have
this idea that maybe life isn't worth
living and things aren't good and then
if they can be smurch let's say to use
an archaic term something that's
pristine and good then they demonstrate
to themselves that there is no true
ideal and that there's no necessary
reason to be responsible and to strive
forward and so they use you as a test
case you know i'll just push you down
into the low lobster bin and see how you
respond and if you put up with it then
yeah my cynicism is fully justified step
number eight confront suffering i've
watched people do very difficult things
like people who work in palliative care
awards so all they're ever dealing with
is pain and death right and they can do
it
they get up in the morning they go to
work and they take care of those people
they lose people on a weekly basis
and yet they can do it and what that
shows is that if you
turn around and you confront the
suffering voluntarily you find out that
you are way tougher than you think it's
not that life is better than you think
life is as harsh as you think it might
even be worse but you are way tougher
than you think if you turn around and
confront it and so then what you
discover is that there's a spirit within
you that pursues some that can pursue
something meaningful that has the
resilience and the strength to contend
properly with the catastrophe of
existence without becoming bitter that's
actually the central so
and then i would say that's one of the
central themes of 12 rules for life is
that make no mistake about it like
the first noble truth of buddhism life
is suffering this is true and it's worse
than that because it's suffering
contaminated by malevolence that's the
baseline but and so that's very
pessimistic but the optimistic part is
that you are so damn tough you can
actually not only deal with that you can
improve it it's like
oh well that's a horrible situation but
it turns out that i'm armed for the task
well that's that's a great thing for
people to know and i do believe i think
the fact that we're armed for the task
is even more true than the fact that
life is catastrophe contaminated by
malevolence we're stronger than things
are terrible so and things are pretty
terrible so that means we're pretty damn
strong wow yes it's a very good thing to
know and it's not naive optimism it's a
very different thing it's like no things
are terrible they're brutal and you are
so damn tough you can't believe it step
number nine struggle up the hill they
say do you believe in god let's say and
my response to that always is well i
don't know what you mean when you ask me
that question so i don't know how to
answer it i don't know what you mean by
believe but i can tell you something
that i believe
and i would say this is a way of
speaking symbolically
i do believe so i was thinking the other
day a week ago i was thinking about this
this little fantasy that entered my mind
i was thinking about saint joseph's
oratorio in montreal and saint joseph's
oratorio is a very large religious
building it's one of the biggest
cathedral-like structures in the world
and it's set on the hill on mount royal
and it's set up where it can catch the
sun you know so it's an image of the
heavenly city on the hill right it's an
image of the structures that we strive
to create that's what it is in
independent of its specifically
christian or religious function that's
what it stands for symbolically okay so
it's the city on the hill it's it's what
we're striving towards when we walk
uphill
in life okay now the way the the
oratorio is structured there's hundreds
of steps leading to it up front and in
the early part of the 20th century a lot
of people who had physical disabilities
came there and they struggled up the
step on their crutches and many of them
left their crutches in the oratorio you
can see hundreds of them if you go there
it's quite an interesting site
and i was thinking about that and i was
thinking about what that meant and this
is what it means it means that
you know everyone has their disabilities
let's say and i know that some people
are far more
terribly affected than other people i'm
perfectly aware of that but the question
is what do you do about that and what
you do is you you set yourself up on
your damn crutches and you struggle up
the bloody hill that's what you do and
you struggle up the hill towards the
kingdom of god that's what you do
because the alternative is to descend
into the abyss
that's the alternative and then so to
say well do you believe it's like i
believe that you should struggle uphill
towards the city of god on your crutches
that's what you should do
that's the opposite of the descent into
the abyss
and so that's that's at the foundation
of our civilization that idea well
argue with it if you will see if you can
figure out why that's not an acceptable
idea maybe you should help someone
struggle up the hill perhaps you should
you know you can lend a hand to someone
although you don't want to take the
burden away from them entirely because
there's something noble about struggling
up the damn hill right there's something
that's adventure that's the call to
proper being it's like well we don't
need to forget this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there since time
immemorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea that's
what gives your life not happiness
forget about that
if it comes well great accept it
dignity nobility
character truth responsibility beauty
those are the things to aim for and step
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is take
responsibility one of the things i've
been talking to my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and and they have the reasons
but you need something to put
up against that
and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better
yeah that's better guilting yourself
you're not feeling bad about yourself
that's right you feel that you've
justified you've justified your
existence right and so you're not waking
up at three in the morning in a cold
sweat thinking about all the terrible
things that you've involved yourself in
what you said to someone that you
shouldn't have said or how you acted or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that
and so
if you think about the times when you're
at peace with yourself with regards to
how you're conducting yourself in the
world it's almost always conditions
under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt i think that you can
experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you
this the baboon here who's supposed to
be basically just a fool when the story
was first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too do not cast pearls before swine
and what that means is that if people
are not listening to you
stop talking to them
and that's really that is the best piece
of advice that i can give you and what
happens is that if you
stop talking to people who aren't
listening to you
and start watching them instead
they will tell you what they're up to
but so if you have things to say you say
them but you find people that will
listen
talk to them the ones who aren't
listening pull back
because you're you're devaluing what you
have to say by offering it to an
audience that does nothing but reject it
and that's a good guideline to life in
general so
pull back in genesis one of the things
god has adam do first so god makes the
world by speaking okay so that's the
first thing to think about
you're supposed to think like
in a sophisticated way about this the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between
communication and the structure of being
it's part of the role that consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so
god has adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now
they're more implicit that's another you
know here's a here's an example let's
say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why
it's unnameable is it real well yeah
it's manifesting itself in a like a
physiological discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing
right and then that's a horrible thing
it's like a little poisonous thing but
it's not a whole
foggy cloud of potential poison it's
like this little sharp poison thing and
then you think okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
precision that's specified you've got to
name them first absolutely because the
unnamable is far more terrifying than
the nameable
you see that in there was this great
blair witch project terrifying movement
well it's unnamed
there's nothing terrible happens in that
movie it's all the unnamable it's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and
no matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put monsters everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you you're the
loser instantly if it's so terrifying
that you cannot face it
it's one my wife is a massage therapist
and she's very
physiologically aware so she's also
helped me with this sort of thing but we
watch people on the streets all the time
and people in general now have very poor
posture yeah very bad for them
that's got to be phone related too right
well yeah i think that's part of it but
i also think it's something our culture
doesn't attend to like you kind of have
to remind your kids to stand up you know
it takes a certain amount of conscious
effort but yeah in that chapter i talk a
lot about lobsters which i'm i'm kind of
i kind of have an affinity for lobsters
and because they
well
the the short story is that when a
lobster loses a fight
because they're fighting all the time
for dominance let's say in their
hierarchies he kind of crunches down so
he looks smaller
when he wins a fight he stretches out
looks bigger and so he's signaling to
other lobsters
the telly of his victories let's say
so if a lobster has won a fight he's
more likely to win the next fight than
you would calculate from having a telly
of all his previous defeats and
victories and if he loses a fight then
he's more likely to lose the next fight
so that's that that matthew principle at
work okay so you think well so what so
what does that have to do with anything
it's like okay
part of the kicker is
while the lobster runs on serotonin
neurochemical
and
if the lobster loses the serotonin
levels go down and if he wins the
serotonin levels go up and when the
serotonin levels go up he stretches out
and he's a confident lobster and one of
the consequences of that is if a lobster
loses a battle
and you give him the equivalent of
antidepressants
then he stretches out and he'll go fight
again so antidepressants work on
lobsters right and you think well who
cares it's like no no no you don't get
it
we diverged from lobsters from an
evolutionary perspective 350 million
years ago and it's the same circuit it's
absolutely unbelievable and that shows
you how deep
inside you how basic how primordial that
circuit is in you that's sizing other
people up and looking at where they fit
in the hierarchy with human society it's
more like hierarchies of competence than
dominance per se
but and like if your
serotonin levels fall
you get depressed you crunch forward and
and the whole everything around you
turns cloudy and black and and then
you're inviting more oppression right
and so you get into this bad
loop you know and so it's really
important to if you're trying to get
your act together it's really important
to stretch yourself out and and sit up
properly because it's it's part of the
psychophysiological loop that can start
you
on the upward curve
and so it's a really important thing to
take note of and like if you've been
bullied
say when you were a kid maybe you've
moved and so it's sort of irrelevant
you're still carrying that with you in
the in the hunched shoulders and then
you can't breathe properly and your
voice isn't right and and you invite
more bullying because the predator types
are always looking for people who
who look like they can be intimidated
and who will make a nice fuss if they
are you know like a nice gratifying
they'll make nice gratifying sounds of
suffering i've had clients many clients
in their 30s who are trying to this is
more true with women i would say a lot
of women who are very high achieving who
establish their career goals at 30 and
then want to differentiate differentiate
out their life they want to have a
husband they want to have a family
they're trying to figure out how to do
that and one of the things i've noticed
that around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you
make sense out of that is that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy
you
yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high and i really mean
that it's like and we'll talk about that
a little bit too aim high but use as
your control yourself it's like so your
goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better you can define better
yourself this doesn't have to be some
imposition of external morality you know
you know where you're weak and
insufficient where you could improve you
think okay well this is what i'm like
yesterday if i did this little thing
things would be just
an increment better
and
well that's a great thing because you
get the ball rolling and
incremental improvement is unstoppable
you can actually implement it and it
starts to generate paredo distribution
like consequences it starts to compound
and i've seen that happen in people's
lives over and over and people write me
all the time and tell me that they're
doing that but i've seen that happen in
people's lives continually they make a
goal a goal that the goal should be
how could i conceive of my life so that
if i had that life it would clearly be
worth living so i wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful one of the things i've learned
if you're
if you have a dispute with someone
and
it needs to be settled and maybe they
need to change more than you and that's
not always the case because sometimes
the settling requires change on your
part but let's say that
they have to be defeated in some sense
in comparison to you you don't want to
defeat them any more than necessary you
know it's like you don't knock your
opponent to the ground and then jump up
and down on them three or four times in
in triumph you know you you
you
you pin them and let and then let them
up
minimal
necessary force
because any more than that just produces
a counter reaction
and so
and i guess the other thing is too is my
motivation
when i'm engaged let's say in these
discussions is that i'm not trying to
win the argument
i'm not trying to win
i'm trying to say what i think as
clearly as i can
and there is
there might be an element
there might be one of the consequences
of that might be
what appears to be a victory but
the right victory is the victory for
your ability to articulate what you
believe
and that's what i'm trying to do and so
that's another reason
to stay composed is like well okay
this person is just throwing a curveball
at me it's like all right so
well
i could be thinking well i don't want to
be undermined by that and i don't want
to make a fool of myself and i don't
want to be put on the spot and of course
all those things are true
but mostly what i'm thinking about is
okay well now i've got that question
i want to answer as truthfully as i
possibly can
what do i think about what was just said
and i'm not calculating the outcome
i'm assuming this is a mark of faith
right this is the faith that
that
people have talked about
being
something that
has to be manifested necessarily we've
been talking about this since the dawn
of time what's the faith
the faith is that if you
say what you believe to be true
then whatever happens is the best thing
that could have happened
and i believe that
so that's and i really believe it
partly because i believe that if you're
deceitful which is the opposite of that
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent
but maybe primarily manipulative
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will
bring victory and i just don't believe
that at all i i just i think it's a
preposterous claim
and so if seed won't bring victory
then truth is what brings victory if
there is such a thing as truth
and there's certainly such a thing as
deceit so there must be such a thing as
truth
and
so and some of it's just curiosity too
it's like well i'm going to say what i
think and see what happens that's an
adventure
you know that's the adventure of your
life
really and you don't want to miss that
because
that's what you've got in your life is
for it to be an adventure
it's not an easy
road you know it's a stormy sea
and
what you have is the adventure of
contending with god and the waves that's
what you have and
the way you do that is with truth
and
then that sort of takes you out of the
immediacy of the conflict whoever it is
that the conflict with whoever it is
that you're talking to
you're trying to ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound
and more lasting when i was a teenager
i mean i i did
god if i had to write a book about the
stupid things i did when i was a
teenager it'd be a very thick book
and it'd be a worse book if there were
photographs accompanying it
and you know but but i had this
advantage that young people today don't
have which was well when my day of
stupidity was over i could go home and
it was not there
you know like it wasn't on twitter it
wasn't on facebook there wasn't 20 of my
friends
communicating to me about you know what
foolish thing i did at the party the
night before and um
and young people now they're just
followed by
paparazzi essentially
constantly and and i've watched that
with the young
teenage daughters of many of my friends
uh because my kids were a little too old
for that to have actually have happened
to them but god it's miserable and
we know that
there is some relationship between the
amount of time people use facebook for
example and their mental health which
mean the more they use facebook the more
depressed they are and it might be that
the depression is driving the facebook
use but the causal pathway seems to be
the other way around which is
you know it's just
playing that unbelievably exposed social
game that's hard on people and these
aren't trivial technologies you know i
mean they're sha they're they're
transforming the way we communicate with
one another and that's and they're
they're completely uncontrolled
experiments we have no idea what the
medium or long-term consequences are
going to be and we'll never find out
either because of course the
communication landscape changes so
quickly that by the time you get adapted
to one
communication technology another one has
come along that's even more confusing
that you now have to master and so
well that's why it's necessary for
everyone to develop their own modicum of
wisdom i believe because
i i don't know how else we're going to
be able to deal with this
technological
transformation that's going to come acro
is already coming across us like a tidal
wave and you know you ain't seen nothing
yet the other people in silicon valley
have plans that
well
that that make you think that the whole
place should probably be bombed just for
the safety of the rest of us
you know because there's
there's tremendous danger in that
rapid acceleration of machine
intelligence and and we have no we have
absolutely no idea where that's headed
so and maybe it'll be great it's it's
possible it'll be great
but
power cuts both ways so
hopefully we can we can control it with
our wisdom and that's pretty much up to
each of you to
put your lives together so you can make
good decisions i don't know what
percentage of human effort is spent in
counterproductive activity you know i
i'm i'm not an absolute cynic about that
but i mean when i talk to undergraduates
i ask them
you know how much
time do you waste every day
by your own
reckoning and
it's somewhere between five and eight
hours you know it's a lot of it's a lot
of time well i usually walk through i
walk the stu students through an
economic analysis of that i said well
you know why don't you value your time
at 50 an hour and calculate for yourself
just exactly what you're doing to your
future by your
inability to discipline yourself it's
worth thinking through
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
when i was 25 or so i probably weighed
about 138 pounds i smoked like packed
cigarettes day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on oil rigs and you know it was
a rough town and we drank a lot i
started when i was 14 and you know
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i quit smoking oh that took
a long time because i eventually had to
quit drinking too in order to quit
smoking and i
started working out i had a fine time
when i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined and i
had to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since i
was
probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when i was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like i
published 15 papers by the time i
graduated with my phd which was by i
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any un graduate student at
that time had ever published at mcgill i
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time i wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my what what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
i had to stop that's a sacrifice i had
to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
over protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind i
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the great father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40.
so then you take people out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from 1 to 10.
so 10 is
make a list of 10 things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number 10
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in what's no longer the
elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that
and then you're met much more
together much more confident and that's
often one of the things that often
happens in situations like that i've
seen this multiple times is that if you
run someone through an exposure training
process like that and and toughen them
up they'll often start standing up to
people around them in a way they never
did before because they wouldn't stand
up for themselves before because they
weren't willing
to undermine the protection
see if you're protecting me
i can't bother you
because i can't afford to forsake your
protection
so if i'm going to play that game i'm
going to be hide behind you then i can't
challenge you
so that's no good because
that's sometimes why people you see this
with guys very frequently they're still
deathly afraid of their father's
judgment when they're in their 30s or
40s it's like well why because they
still want to believe that there's
someone out there that knows
and so they're willing to accept the
subjugation because it doesn't force
them to challenge the idea that there's
someone out there that knows i had a
plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and
he had put in all the plastic piping you
know and i was going to test the joints
they're supposed to be glued together
with this pipe glue right and i said i
told him i had to test the joints and he
said well you don't have to test my
joints they never leak and i thought
yeah that's okay how about if i test
them so i went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water capping them
in the basement like you're supposed to
like half an hour later i had two inches
of water in the basement there were 30
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable uh forthright productive way
of making a living and there is a hell
of a lot of difference between a working
man who knows what he's doing and one
who doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what the hell are you going to do if
you don't try to aim for the top you
know flap about uselessly and whine
about your life it's not helpful it'll
just make you miserable you're not
reliable to anyone you can't help out in
a crisis it's like so you tell young
people and this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there and
make something of yourself for god's
sake be an honest person and work and
get to the top of whatever it is that
you want to get to the top of you know
and and and
and that stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard a month
ago month and a half he used to teach
there and i talked to a bunch of
students you know and i told them
it's not easy to get into harvard you
know like you're a valedictorian if
you're at harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am i saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids
so i told them what i just told you it's
like here you are at harvard it's like
get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out make it schedule and stick to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule
it's not a bloody prison that's the
first thing that people do wrong they
say well i don't like to have follow a
schedule it's like well what kind of
schedule are you setting up well i have
to do this then i have to do this then i
have to do this you know and then i just
go play video games because who wants to
do all these things that i have to do
it's like wrong
set the schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that than at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well i've got these
responsibilities i have to schedule the
things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who was working for you it's like okay
you gotta work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
gonna do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
percent the next week or 50 and a half
percent for god's sake or because
you're you're going to hit that position
where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward the
next best predictor of lifetime success
is conscientiousness well so and of the
of the two aspects of conscientiousness
say orderliness and and industriousness
the better predictor is industriousness
so the question is well what can you do
about your industriousness and the
answer to that is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes i think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that and basically it does a
situational analysis of it helps you do
a situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis i would
say and so the questions are something
like well
all right you're gonna have to put some
effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in neuroticism you want security
okay so those are all sources of
potential motivation that you could draw
on that you could tailor to your own you
know your own personality but then there
are dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about well you know if you could have
your life the way you wanted it in three
to five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to augur down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control and
then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the microprocessors become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want you want to specify
goals that make you say oh if that could
happen as a consequence of my efforts it
would clearly be worthwhile because the
question always is why do something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy the question is why
would you ever do anything and the
answer that has to be because you've
determined by some
means that it's worthwhile and then the
next question might be well where should
you look for worthwhile things and one
would be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the life span
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the sub components of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once but once you set up that that
goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
you use everything you learn as a means
of building that person that you want to
be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap
and it's important to distinguish
between those because that's partly and
this is back down to the micro routine
analysis so if i was saying well you're
going to try to make yourself more
industrious okay number one specify your
goals because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy which is
real easy because that's just a matter
of not doing as well then you don't know
when you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful so i'll keep myself blind about
when i fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done
and that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
so so
i would recommend that you don't let
that happen so that's willful blindness
right you could have known but you chose
not to okay so once you get your goal
structure set up you think okay if i
could have this life looks like that
might be worth living despite the fact
that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort have a
routine that's disciplined that's
predictable and bloody well stick to it
you're going to be way
healthier and happier and saner if you
do that and then the other thing that
you need because this is one of the
things the psychoanalyst got wrong i
think is that they overestimated the
degree to which sanity was a consequence
of internal
of being properly structured internally
you know
because from the psychoanalytic point of
view you're sort of an ego and that ego
is inside you and of course it rests on
an unconscious structure but the purpose
of psychoanal analysis is to sort out
that unconscious structure and the ego
on top of it and to make you a fully
functioning and autonomous individual
but there's a problem with that because
the reason that you're saying as a fully
functional and autonomous human being
isn't because you've organized your
psyche even though that's important
the reason that you're saying if you're
away if you have a well organized
unconscious and ego is because other
people can tolerate having you around
for reasonably extensive periods of time
and will cuff you across the back of the
head every time you do something so
stupid that people will dislike you
permanently if you continue
and so what people are doing to each
other all the time just non-stop is
broadcasting sanity signals back and
forth right it's like you smile at
people if they're well if they're not
not only behaving properly but behaving
in a way that you would like to see them
continue to behave you frown at them if
they're not you ignore them if they're
not you shun them you you roll your eyes
at them you manifest a disgust face you
don't listen to them you interrupt them
you won't cooperate with them you won't
compete with them it's like you're
blasting signals at other people about
how to regulate their behavior so
frequently well it just makes up all of
your social interaction that's why we
face each other and we have emotional
displays on our face and we're looking
at each other's eyes and we know exactly
we know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself as a
credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape
making sure that that's exactly what you
are
and that's how you stay sane and so what
happens to people too if they don't have
a routine and they get isolated is they
start to drift and they drift badly
because the world is too complicated for
you to keep it organized all by yourself
you just cannot do it so a lot of our so
we outsource the problem of sanity
and it's very intelligent that we
outsource the problem of sanity because
sanity is an impossibly complex problem
and so the way that we manage the
incredibly complex problem is we have a
very large number of brains working
simultaneously on the problem all the
time plan a life you'd like to have and
and you do that partly by
referring to social norms that's more or
less rescuing your father from the belly
of the whale but the way other way you
do that is by having a little
conversation with yourself about
as if you don't really know who you are
because you know what you're like you
won't do what you're told you won't do
what you tell yourself to do you must
have noticed that it's like you're a bad
employee and a worse boss and both of
those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but
but you know what my point is is that
you have to understand that you're not
your own servant so to speak you're
someone that you have to negotiate with
and that's and you're someone that you
want to present the opportunity of
having a good life to and that's hard
for people because they don't like
themselves very much
so you know they're always like cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and it's like god it's
so boring and
such a pathetic way of spending your
time i started to pay very careful
attention to what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas
and there was another part that was
watching that part like
just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like
well which of those two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know was that me or was the part
that was going about my normal verbal
business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as the coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen
if you want even more motivation from
jordan peterson check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's a fairly it's a fairly
limited attempt first of all we're not
going to say that you know